ah business partners I mean the most
important thing about our partnership is
it's not based on cuddly love and
affection I mean over 35 years I mean I
by many definitions he has to be my best
friend I mean he's he's the person I
talked to when my mom and dad died he
was there with my you know right after
my children were born he's all of those
things but we're much more like two guys
who own a dry-cleaning business you know
many of your show business partnerships
start in love I mean letting the
McCartney had a love affair pretty
clearly Martin and Lewis had a love
affair Jagger and Richards had a love
affair and when that goes south when all
of a sudden love fades away it becomes a
huge explosion I mean Lennon and
McCartney hated each other and with
working with teller there was no real
attraction we didn't want to spend all
our time together we spent all our time
together but we weren't dying it to do
that what we wanted to do was do a show
together and we had much more respect
and affection and I think there's a lot
to be learned from how how much stronger
respect is than affection for one we
understand respect and we don't
understand affection so it's a little
easier to get it get your mind around
and be able to manipulate and so when
teller and I don't like each other when
we're not getting along doesn't change
much of anything you know it's like when
you working at the 7-eleven you don't
quite get along with the guy who's
cleaning the Slurpee machine that day
you don't care that much your life goes
on so he's become my best friend but in
a in a very circuitous route you know
through through respect and through work
I think if you were to picture what we
what we do you probably be pretty right
I tend to have the responsibility for
what I say there are lines here and
there that are tellers there are moments
in the in the shape of the plot of
things that are tellers but for the most
part I'm in charge of what I say and for
the most part of tellers in charge of
the magic now there are great lines in
the show that came from teller and there
are slightly clever magic moments that
come from me and we do work together on
things but those are really the
responsibilities if you wanted to break
it down in in really traditional terms I
think you would see teller as kind of
the director I kind of directs the show
and I don't care very much about staging
lights how things look in my mind I'm
always doing a radio show